I don't think we give ourselves enough
leeway to push ourselves to our limits
24 hours is a long time I was running
for 13 and after 55 days I'd cross
America when things get tough especially
in Ultra or in life in general I'll
think in my head like can I take another
step and you absolutely basically always
can there's very few moments in life
where physically you can't take another
step you just have to understand that
the process starts at day one I don't
think I'm inherently special gifted
talented whatsoever but my mission and
my reasoning behind it will always push
me to to keep going so if I can I will
if you think about that really deeply
you can and you will